where
are you coming from
spirituality is about realignment
to the one heart realignment to the one
intelligence realignment
to source as
where you're coming from
rather than coming from person
conditioning
coming from source means knowing your
nature as source it means knowing your
nature
as the one infinite creator it means
knowing your nature
as intelligent infinity
coming from the point of being
the one intelligence at play with itself
in this creation rather than
coming from the identity of being a
person
so you have to go all the way upstream
to source and identify
as source identify as
the one intelligence identify as
the one infinite creator as intelligent
infinity
itself at play
in this creation
and see that everywhere you look
so right now if you're feeling a
contracted
person identity you are stuck
downstream and you don't know yourself
you have to go through this so-called
veilless veil this so-called gateless
gate and all that means
in this process of awakening or
enlightenment
is simply popping yourself from the
person
identity going more
upstream towards source and the first
pop is typically becoming aware of
awareness
itself
becoming aware of consciousness becoming
aware
of witnessing or observation
and as you become aware of the very
paramountness
of awareness itself
you do these so-called gym repetitions
in abiding more and more as the very
formless subtle awareness
rather than the very dense physical
personhood
then you recognize that even awareness
itself
comes from the same source therefore
awareness is shared awareness is
impersonal
so then you begin recognizing that even
the people that you talk to
are having a unique angle
of the same awareness and so you
shoot yourself even more upstream
towards your source
and you begin seeing the multi-angled
perspectives of the same awareness
you begin holding the so-called ant
colony
view where you can hold the view
more and more of not just two
perspectives of awareness but you can
hold a whole
city of awareness you can hold the whole
planet
of awareness this is what is known as
the
all-inclusive awareness the very
great i am
so now you've moved significantly
upstream
from person identity to the much more
pop into the formless subtle
personal awareness and then into the
shared impersonal awareness
and then you become more and more
recognized
that the all-inclusive awareness
is eternally the witness
of infinite creation and this
is but one of our creations
as source this is one of our
lila one of our divine plays
so the next so-called pop
is to recognize that even awareness the
very
all-inclusive awareness is being
observed as krishnamurti says
the observer is observed
so pop yourself again from
the all-inclusive observer to what
observes
the all-inclusive observer and that is
what is known as your source
so now what you see is you see
that you are source you begin
identifying yourself as source and not
even as the all-inclusive awareness
you could call as bentino massaro says
the all-inclusive awareness
as the very first or last
attribute before you get to the
agent-less
the attributeless source
the very near goona brahman the
attributeless
brahman the attributeless absolute
so then you add your first attribute
your very first
attribute is the all-inclusive awareness
so now you've identified yourself as
source you're way upstream you're at the
highest
upstream you can possibly go your source
you begin identifying yourself a source
and you begin
coming from the place of source
manifesting the all-inclusive awareness
manifesting the reality of planet earth
and then being this one intelligence at
play on the planet
so now everywhere you look you begin
seeing that one intelligence at play so
you come
from source and you can't commit
malevolence you can't commit suffering
because now you know everything as
yourself
you know everything as your body
everything is your own love light at
play with itself
so the utility the practicality of
awakening of enlightenment
is the eradication of suffering because
you know
yourself
you know your very most upstream true
nature as
source creating these realities in
exploration
everywhere you look you no longer come
from being a conditioned
person wanting to extract
peace and happiness from other people
from experiences from
relationships from substances from
maya from the illusion from the
intoxication
of the creation
as is told in the archotypal story of
the parable of the prodigal son you
venture outward trying to extract that
peace and happiness until you
hit the breaking point where the sludge
hammer of suffering comes and
whaps you hard enough to where you're
forced to turn
inward and as you turn inward you
investigate the nature of this very
formless subtle awareness itself
and you recognize that it is eternal it
is impersonal
and its nature is joy and peace
which is what is meant by satchit ananda
existence consciousness bliss
so you see in the process of
popping away from personhood
conditioning closer and closer towards
your true nature
the very utility the very practicality
of enlightenment and awakening
is the eradication of suffering
and in doing so it's the maximizing of
human potential when you interact with
somebody
you don't do it from the perception of
i am a physical finite entity
interacting with a physical
finite entity that are separate from
each other in a physical planet
rather you begin doing it from the
perspective of
this is all one infinite
source intelligence at play with itself
therefore this is an expression it's a
unique
beautiful firework and this is an
expression in a unique beautiful
firework
and they are both that same source at
play with itself
it's a completely different perspective
on the nature of reality and in doing so
the utility
the practicality is the eradication of
suffering
and the maximizing of our potential here
you no longer try and extract peace and
happiness
instead you radiate like the sun
which is what is meant by enlightenment
you radiate
peace and happiness and you butterfly
effect that
out
so again the whole game is about
identity
the whole game is about where you're
coming from if you're coming from source
if you identify
as source you literally begin
identifying
your presence itself
as source manifesting awareness
manifesting reality
and when you come from the perspective
of source manifesting awareness and
manifesting reality
you purify where you're coming from to
the point where you no longer associate
yourself with your personhood
conditioning
but rather you begin associating
yourself again as that one intelligence
at play with itself and being in pure
service to others
so again everywhere you look see source
at play with itself
practice that those are your gym
repetitions
the very simple abiding process
everywhere you look see it as lila as
the divine
play of the one intelligence with
itself when you interact with someone it
is the one intelligence interacting with
itself
and practice expanding your awareness
out to include
the two angles that you're currently
in a conversation with out of your own
personal awareness into the impersonal
awareness
of two angles three angles four angles
the entire planet of
angles simultaneously
so again you're no longer seeing
separate physical entities you're seeing
source at play with itself
you purify and check yourself
relentlessly
vigilantly this is what's meant by
spirituality the realignment
to the one heart to the supreme
to source to the absolute relentlessly
purifying and checking yourself where
are you coming from it shows up more and
more subtly
as you awaken as you enlighten and you
go through these pops
you become more and more subtly aware of
where you're coming from
and if you're coming from your person
conditioning one of those
onion layers or if you're coming
from source you're not coming from a
place
of lack or need
which we'll get to here in a moment
repeatedly relentlessly check where
you're coming from
and when you come from the source again
of awareness and of realities repeatedly
you will begin seeing that everywhere
you'll begin seeing everything as
intelligent infinity as the one infinite
creator and the practicality again of
that is you won't commit
malevolence because you will know that
that is you
you are that you are it
all
so drop your attachments drop the need
to be validated
and drop the description describing of
experience
for two to five seconds repeatedly until
you literally come
from source to awareness
to reality to a one intelligence
at play with itself
so if we do that right now
together let's do this exercise
take a breath
and relax
take another breath
and relax
drop describing your experience
and just relax into the very
nature of i am
ah use the breath to relax yourself more
and as you stop describing your
experience
and you begin just abiding
in the very nature of
that you are
that i am
what i want you to practice doing now
is to practice recognizing that
we all come from the same
source now if you need to
close your eyes take another deep breath
relax
and visualize the very nature
of all coming from the same
source
visualize how awareness and
reality itself come from
the same source
visualize how we are all that
one intelligence at play
with itself
visualize how the one intelligence
uses awareness and realities
to explore to play
with itself
these are your gym repetitions
repeatedly abide in this very
exercise and begin
seeing your true nature
as the one intelligence
the very source of awareness
and reality at play
with itself
take a deep breath and relax
into
the very truth of what you just
experienced
let it sit with you
reflect on it integrate it
and abide as it
you are source
come from source
thank you
you